la mode avec cette invitation au voyage
signée yves saint laurent de la chine à
la russie des ans de l'afrique des
collections inspirées de ses multiples
cultures est exposée la fondation pierre
bergé yves saint laurent jusqu'au 25
avril
estelle colin tristan le braz depuis
toujours
yves saint laurent donne l'impression de
s'excuser d'avoir du talent mais comment
pourrait-on ne pas lui pardonner ses
perles c'est l'afrique qui ne voient le
japon à travers ce kimono la russie
l'inde l'espagne ou la chine
avec cette exposition est alors on nous
invite dans son voyage immobile saut au
marbre
comment vous avez plus de votre empire
en fouillant de connaître tente un rush
regardez
des limes
je sais mais plus au voyage
chez avec des libres sur mon kanak est
dans mon salon
à travers l'imaginaire 10 alors on s'est
écrit près d'un demi siècle d'histoire
de la mode
on a tous les trésors depuis une
première collection printemps-été 62
jusqu'à dernière collection printemps le
printemps 2002 les depuis monsieur ne
dit non plus pourtant chaque jour
devient que plus tard à orly en idées
des journaux et des commentaires ce test
de théâtre acteur ou pas quarante ans de
création
toute une époque l'entourage enluminent
de souvenirs le chef d'atelier entré
dans le studio avec le même qu'à
habiller avec la robe que nous avions
fait il faut rien faire et là monsieur
sans leur en savoie sera pas des
retouches là et nous mettions à la porte
pour pas déranger le
inspiration de monsieur saint laurent et
lignée de création que dans la
souffrance
on peut dire qu'ils sont alors en
incarne la création la retenue qui
l'expriment face à une horde de
photographes tout comme à une salve de
compliments cache une certaine douleur
c'est de faire part
key